The web is visual.
Well, obviously,
otherwise this course wouldn't exist.
But not all people surfing the web have
the ability to see images like this one.
For the visually impaired,
screen readers are essential
to make sense of the web.
This is Lynx.
It's an all text browser and
this is what Reddit looks like on Lynx.
Without images, this is all a user
has to decipher your website and
they usually won't even be reading it.
They'll be hearing it through
a screen reader like ChromeVox.
The good news is that you can
still make images meaningful
by using alt attributes responsibly.
Here, let me show you what I mean.
I've enabled ChromeVox,
which is a screen reader that
will be reading this page to you.
Here, let's see what it has to say.
>> The internet thanks you for
being responsible with your alt tags.
To replicate the experience of being
visually impaired, I'm giving you
some information using images that
don't make any sense on their own,
or at all, really.
Don't leave your visually impaired
visitors out in the cold.
Here are some tips about alt tags.
Alt tags should be descriptive for
important images,
like this body surfer because body
surfing is important, I guess.
Alt tags should be empty for
images that are just decorations,
like this boiler image.
Do you get the joke?
It's a boiler to represent
boilerplate code,
which is sometimes empty of content.
Alt tags should be set on every image
just like this pig is set on being so
darn cute.
>> So there you have it.
Check the instructor notes if you
want to see the tips that ChromeVox
just read to you.
Oh, and by the way, to get ChromeVox,
it's just a Chrome extension,
so it's really easy to install.